but what was more interesting for us to
understand that there the data
is a lot more valuable for the the
manufacturers
because if they understand how their
brands are consumed
they can do something about it welcome
to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community
fund in silicon valley in partnership
with leumitech
sponsored by hippo insurance opposed
labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech beer
and technology two of some of the most
interesting and
enjoyable pieces of many people's lives
and today i'm honored to be joined by
ori finger co-founder and chief business
development officer at weisberger
a really interesting company that found
a really interesting
intersection between the two in his
early twenties ori started a company
that aimed to monitor kindergartens
through on-site cameras to prevent
any violent or uncomfortable behavior
towards children this startup did not
evolve as hoped
but did spark the first life for being
an entrepreneur
following that orie pursued
entrepreneurship in real estate finished
the law degree and internship
and went to start up a company in the
beer industry along his long-time army
friend omar aguive
pre-its acquisition weisberger raised
more than 15 million dollars from top
investors like
gigi levy innovation endeavors icv and
others
or he likes to enjoy running in his
spare time football fanatic and the
father of two energetic boys
holy finger welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm great mikhail thank you for having
me
i'm excited to host here the chief
business development
at weisberger big data beer two things
that i perhaps love most in life
except for my dog benny of course but uh
i i just love what you're doing at
weisberger i got to visit your offices a
couple years ago
uh and it was just a great experience
even before you were
you were sold to a bin bev and uh and
now i can't
i can only imagine you know the sky's
the limit but ali tell me a little bit
about yourself and i'm gonna have to
start with your fun fact
having two middle fingers attached on
both legs
with the last name finger is that just a
crazy coincidence
yeah well actually it never occurred my
mind
to link between these two phenomenons my
my uh last name and
the fact that they have two toes that
are uh
a bit attached even more than just a bit
uh
i was thinking a lot about that fun fact
before i
you know i released the news uh but
that's the way i was born
a bit like the turtles you know the
ninja turtles uh that they have their
fingers attached so um
but it never really helped my uh
swimming skills it's just something you
learn to live with so
you can uh you know overcome it
definitely a hundred percent really your
your trajectory in the tech scene and
outside of the type scene
from monitoring kindergartens to prevent
violence
to real estate and law and back to big
data and
and ending up with beer so you did the
right track obviously
tell me a little bit about you know your
sense of entrepreneurial spirit
going through the years how is that how
does it blossom throughout these
different experiences
so i was brought up in a family uh that
is
pretty much packed with with lawyers my
dad is lawyer my
both my sisters uh grew up to become
lawyers too
one of them shifted to uh to interior
design but in any case
uh you know i had this uh type of
expectation set
so i i went on to um to have a degree in
law to do the internship here in tel
aviv
but i never really i was never really
bought into this world of becoming an
actual lawyer so
even during my internship i um
i partnered with my best friend from the
army time homer i give
and together we we founded weiss
billiard
but before that um just after i finished
the army
i remember it was an interesting time
when uh kindergarten
had some challenging um
uh incidents let's call it that are
becoming a lot more common nowadays but
that was
at stake about 16 17 years ago
and i had this idea of of tracking
kindergartens from remote having
access giving access to parents to see
what happens to their
children throughout the day uh but it
was times uh
when um the regulation just for
prohibited that
uh significantly but it was the first
time
that i actually took a stab at writing a
business plan and and
starting to research uh you know a space
to see how what the size of the
opportunities etc etc
um i even went to like a mentorship
program to understand better how to do
that because i was really
clueless at that time so it didn't it
didn't materialize to fundraising
and uh commercial but uh i went and
signed up a few kindle gardens and
signed the
uh quite a bit of parents that that
wanted this to happen
but it was the the first experience i
would say of um
entrepreneurship in a sense
and then in terms of real estate when i
was about
in my early 20s my dad gave me um like
20 000 dollars he said
go on do something productive with this
so in in haifa where i grew up at that
time it was uh
enough to uh buy something uh a small
apartment
um and then um throughout the years i i
played with the idea of renovating and
um
etc and it was interesting and something
that i i had passion to but
real estate is more about the financial
play and i wanted to do something that i
also have passion to
and beer is a big passion right um
so moving forward at about 2011
uh we identified a huge gap in in a very
old-fashioned industry at the time
uh you know nowadays 2021 there's in
every organization there's a chief
information officer
chief innovation uh big data is such a
overused word in a sense um
but at that time they simply did not
have visibility to what's happening
in the in the stores in the bars and
restaurants
and what we wanted to do is provide
these large corporates with visibility
to help them basically become a lot more
efficient
and base their decision-making processes
on data
so we started with an iot uh
company that later on evolved into a
much more uh technology-driven um
uh api based to pull data from point of
sale and help
both store and buy owners and
on the other and also the the companies
um
and it's really it was a
transformational uh
move in that industry so
take me you know take me thousand thirty
thousand feet in the air
you're looking at the bra industry and
i'm looking at bar owners and restaurant
owners and i
get to live here in in beautiful tel
aviv and i'm watching the this
massive operation take place how does
data
build into this whole you know beer
management
you know ecosystem or supply chain if
you will
from the manufacturer to the
from the brewer all the way to the bar
how does that you know
integrate all that so we actually it
started a bit differently
when we just set up we wanted to put we
put actually
uh we installed um beer taps
at the actual tables in restaurants so
take for for instance about that has 20
20 tables and then uh 50 uh spots
on its bar to sit in and then um
we collect from we enabled the diners to
actually pour
beer as much as they want from that uh
from that
beer for that beer system and they can
drink as much as they want and they have
like a counter that tells them okay you
drink
x amounts and you can you don't you you
don't necessarily have to drink half a
pint or
or pints etc and then you pay as much as
you drink
and it turned out that it accelerated or
increased
the the amounts that people drink
because they don't need to wait on a
waiter or waitress
to uh to to serve them right but what
was more interesting for us to
understand that their the data
is a lot more valuable for the the
manufacturers
because if they understand how their
brands are consumed
they can do something about it and they
simply did not have a way to do that
right because what i'm imagining is that
you know they're selling the beers in
barrels and then you know
a full barrel is a lot and i imagine
that quite frequently
bars don't fulfill the entire barrel
before it's done it's unusable and so
they don't actually have a grasp and how
how are consumers actually drinking us
so are they enjoying
you know just a pint maybe a half maybe
a third who knows
how they're drinking right and then it
they can
actually modify the beer if they knew
how the customers are reacting
yeah but the interesting piece about it
uh mikhail and
you know talking about startup life the
amount of knows of negative answers
that we receive when you know when we
started having this idea we went to
uh the leaders of the israeli beverage
uh
ecosystem let's call it ceos cmos
uh of the top companies in israel that
are leading this space and
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of shekels and perhaps even billions of
shekels
uh type of companies and all of them
told us
guys this is like a waste of time
you should either retire completely or
move to a shift to uh
tracking oils from machinery heavy
machinery
factories uh and gave us a very cold
shoulder
um i you know the amount of time i left
meetings saying okay this is like this
is the end of the road is
count like you cannot really count how
many times happened
luckily for me i had uh omer as a
partner who constantly what
it was an amazing meeting like this is
just this is just the beginning
like were we at the same meeting just
now
so uh you know you need to you need to
have a partner that complements you
and i think we we we are like that but
really now it's it's kind of funny to
meet these type of people who told us
listen this is there will be no demand
for you guys in the industry and now
we're a part of the world's
largest beer company which is
you know um according this is a public
company
so it's about 50 billion in revenues
annually and um
it's like by far the biggest outdoor so
uh it's it's a good journey overall uh
was there a aha moment throughout the
way because i'm hearing that in the
beginning there was a lot of skepticism
and you have a wonderful co-founder of
omelet that that can push forward
and it sounds like the two of you
complement each other quite quite
beautifully
was there an aha moment where you said
you know what
we heard a lot of no's but this moment
proved to us
that we actually have something that we
can hold on to is there or was it more
you know just along the way so actually
there is no aha moment
unfortunately uh there's just like a lot
of okay there's demand to
it uh companies are willing to pay for
it
companies are willing to scale with this
uh
and then you understand that you have
something concrete
but until you're joining forces and you
know
people are actually i think the
acquisition is somewhat of an aha moment
uh that concludes everything you're
saying okay that's there's no better
stamp than
there is the room for this right uh but
it was quite a journey just to
uh to put in perspective it took us
about seven years
uh so it wasn't it wasn't one of those
uh 18 months
type of stories you hear about nowadays
so now that you're working with you know
the beer industry traditional industry
and i imagine that a lot of the people
in the in your day to day
don't necessarily talk in the same you
know slang
and the same the same work environment
that you're used to
from an israeli startup perspective do
you
find that there are differences or
clashes or
changes of mentality in your day-to-day
yeah so there there are none and i'll
tell you why many people that that
meet you post acquisition they're like
so how are you gonna stay there like uh
what's keeping you there you know we
israelis we know best right
and you're joining the world's giant
uh beer company and turns out there's
a lot to learn uh to say the least like
these guys are pros there's a reason why
they're so good at what they do
it's not they it's actually we like
we're definitely part a part of the
family
uh but the interesting thing about a b
invert is that they
became a technology giant too
so in the last few years they opened so
many different arms that
simply deal with with innovation and
technology and acquisition of
we were and that's interesting we were
the first technological acquisition of a
b
in the history which we should not be
taking lightly you know we're not a
cyber security sp
in the cyber security space where a
beverage uh
started doing you know what we call
bevtech
so it's it's it is outstanding but
nowadays they are so much focused on on
developing technologies
and they speak the same language and
they teach us every day a lot so it's a
very
nurturing kind of um relationship
and so if we look today at you know the
beer market
and the trade you know the way that
either the bar from the bars perspective
or from the brewery manufacturing
perspective
what what is left so what can we get
excited about
in the introduction of technology to
this traditional
you know older type of business or what
is left
so actually we did not plan that
michelle
you know that but it you're actually
leading me to the
to the interesting piece we it took us
quite some time to find our role in the
organization in such a huge company
over a hundred thousand employees maybe
in that wow
and uh we're now
70 plus uh wow
and and we i think uh the organization
had
the right kind of patience uh to find uh
what they can
how they can best utilize our our
resources our
data analytics capabilities and
we are now a part of an arm which is
called these
this is a b inverse b to b play
that leads their digital transformation
uh process
and basically it enables store owners
bowen restaurant owners
to order their merchandise through a
marketplace an online marketplace
it may sound basic but it's unbelievable
because
people all over latam all over latin
america that used to
call their sales rep and tell them how
many cases of beer and
and cans and bottles they want to order
now they simply go online
they have a very simple
and strong app to use which is called
bees
and we are we receive the mandate to
lead innovation and the analytics
layers one of that of that app so
you know we hear the different numbers
of b2b plays in israel
b2b companies b2b marketplaces
b's without mentioning getting too uh
into the
numbers uh too far but it's
it has over a million users
b2b so we're now a part of a company
that services over one million
uh b2b um users which is
unbelievable um and
it's really one of the top globally
uh so so we're very lucky to uh to do
that there's not a lot of company
in companies in israel if at all that
can do just that right
and then just to put in perspective uh
you know we hear a lot about
acquisitions and mergers and then the
difficulties with
and then you're describing on one hand
tremendous responsibility
a great pride obviously from the israeli
ecosystem to have
an israeli-led group that has such a
responsibility but at the end you're
0.1 of the organization that you're that
you're joining in yet you're
holding so much of the responsibility
and i think that's always that that's
always an amazing lesson that i learned
that you in the biggest organizations
the the big big things
sometimes happen from very small groups
of people that are just
very innovative you know 10 years later
it's been 10 years since you know 2011
where where are you now what gets you
excited every day to wake up
walk into the same you know the
organization that you're part of
and say i'm still passionate about this
i think as i as i said earlier the
ability to learn
like these immense uh just think about
you have the top
guys in every aspect of the business you
can learn from
so that's one thing um and on top of
that
it's the ability to make an impact to a
purpose we're now
literally impacting the lives of smbs
across so many markets and this solution
is only expanding
so the ability to help people do better
business
is is such a good cause and i it may
sound like a cliche but
how many companies can really say that
they're impacting
lives nowadays uh
there are they exist thankfully but not
a ton of companies right
and then they only be so so much
thank you and that's that's the most
important part
india and thank you really for coming
here it's been really a pleasure i have
a few fun questions that i cannot skip
are you ready for them i think
let's see okay so we'll get started easy
we'll get a little bit more complicated
easy question first favorite subject in
school k-12
yeah well i thought about this i was not
the best student
i was more focused on the social uh
social aspect of things
but uh sociology um
was always something that i liked
some somehow led me to a bit of
interesting being interested in politics
etc
if i need to pick but not mathematics
not
physics not computer science uh i did
all
besides computer science
i love that okay one of your role models
or somebody that
you look up to somebody that inspires
you
so you know when i read it the first
name that came to mind was it
i don't know if you got that previously
um
but if i have to define to define the
characteristics
then i think nowadays it's even more
challenging to find someone who's not
afraid to speak their minds
even when it doesn't serve their
interests
everyone are you know doing whatever
will
you know get them to uh to their
ultimate goal right
so i think people that pick their minds
without being afraid of the concerns
there is a great podcast that actually
here and i like the guy because he
like he serves some he's not he's not uh
an idol but um scott galloway
you do you follow it prof g okay
i love that okay and the last question
that i have for you three words
that you would choose to describe
yourself
perseverance drive and
um and which one i actually wrote it
down
somewhere wait uh ambitious
i love that oh wait thank you very very
much it was really a pleasure
and best of luck with everything that
you're doing i love the journey and
i love you know the insights from also
the internally and the ability to
continuously learn and
and not look for the for the quick you
know exit but but really you know
gain passion for what you're doing and
having so much tremendous responsibility
within and within such an incredible
organization holy thank you very very
much for joining
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you for having
you